aussi l'annonce ce matin du trimestre
anti-inflation par Bruno Le Maire et en
compagnie des mousquetaires et des
patrons de la grande distribution la
grande distrib comme on dit en capital
je crois la liberté de commerce d'accord
mais concrètement qu'est-ce que la
liberté de commerce monsieur le ministre
donc la liberté de commerce c'est la
liberté de commerce
[Rires]
chez Carrefour 200 articles seront ainsi
proposés à moins de 2 euros sans
produits qui ont un nutri-score A ou B
et sans produit du quotidien comme les
lait si vous les couches chez Système U
ce seront 150 produits à prix coûtant
Intermarché lui voit plus large avec 500
produits anti-inflation
470 des marques distributeurs et 30
produits frais c'est le système
il y a pas moyen que je parle un seul
jour et d'ailleurs au sein de
l'agriculture tout le monde te l'a dit
sans que je sois coupé 800 fois et après
je garde
personne
vous vous attendez à quoi comme
animation pour un dîner feria je sais
pas moi une soirée j'en sais rien
là-haut sur le toit franchement j'ai
pensé plein de choses dans ma tête mais
je savais pas du tout où y mettre ma
tête
bon je suis conne là j'ai l'impression
qu'on tient un truc alors le macrame est
déjà rappelons le principe du macramé ce
sont des nœuds avec des fils de corde et
on fait ben c'est plus les napperons
mais on peut faire des tentures pour
décorer chez soi voilà j'avais un peu de
temps libre je fais ça on organise un
dîner
d'accord mercredi prochain
on sent que tu as fait les choses de
manière séparée avant de les rassembler
en fait j'ai cuit tous les ingrédients à
part sauf le riz en fait non je raconte
des bêtises que le riz je l'ai rissolé
avant on m'a dit ça ça retire l'amidon
l'amidon c'est ce qu'il y a sur les
pâtes et le riz et c'est ce qui fait
coller tu vois franchement j'ai rien
compris Mister français
comment ça va tu es heureux
quel est le poisson que l'on peut raser
le mérou parce que la peau de mérou se
tond
la poudre mérouston
[Applaudissements]
c'est les grosses têtes
55700 pénis ont été mesurés et le
résultat est sans appel la longueur de
nos phallus à augmenter de 25% en 30 ans
en 1992 la verge moyenne en érection
faisait 12 cm elle dépasse aujourd'hui
les 15 cm le constat est d'autant plus
étonnant Elizabeth que tous les autres
indicateurs sont à la baisse c'est un
peu mou mais c'est bien quand même
mais alors comment expliquer ce quart de
phalus en plus et bah certains
scientifiques évoquent l'exposition aux
perturbateurs endocriniens aux
pesticides voire aux engrais qui ne
feraient donc pas pousser que les
plantes et pour l'instant aucun
chercheur n'est vraiment capable de
prédire quand et où s'arrêtera la
croissance des verges des générations
futures
est-ce que tu te considères comme un
comme un beau gosse
bah forcément ce concours je pensais pas
que j'étais moche mais c'est
pas ça
je me suis jamais présenté
je me présenterai pas
ce que vous allez voir n'est pas une
parodie
à mon commandement garde-à-vous
en avant mars
la rivière
l'engagement
la discipline
nous avons découvert et c'est la
première fois les talents d'interprète
de la Marseillaise car contrairement à
son habitude son micro était ouvert on a
poussé le son et je l'aurais je l'aurais
pas imaginé je chantais comme ça il s'y
croit vraiment
[Musique]
d'où sort ce jour de gloire est arrivé
dans c'est vraiment savoir on n'a pas
trafiqué juste pour monter le son
[Musique]
alors oui ça l'a échappé à personne il
y avait une flûte qui me chassa
on voit bien le socle de la cohésion
exactement le creuser de la
creusetième
là pendant toute cette année c'est quoi
l'année de parce que l'année de Miss
France on la connaît
[Musique]
ici tu vois toi c'est quoi c'est pareil
tu vas aller dans les foires dans la
saucisse tout ça
je vais participer à Fort du groupe la
France est le pays où la grande
distribution et où les fast-foods ce
sont le plus rapidement développés
massivement des après les États-Unis en
proportion même plus aux États-Unis le
phénomène est apparemmentable il n'y a
pas d'Arsenal légal ni de procédure
politique ou administrative qui empêche
voilà si c'était l'éducation des
citoyens c'est du poison c'est de la
régression sociale c'est de la pure
malbouffe c'est totalement dégueulasse
on peut faire autre chose non mais c'est
de la merde peut-on retomber enceinte
avec un stérilet la réponse là aussi oui
bien évidemment et qu'est-ce qu'il
devient ce stérilet une fois que le bébé
né un bébé stérilet regardez une photo
qui a fait le buzz tout le weekend
photos que j'aime beaucoup un bébé qui
est sorti et qui a rapporté son petit
stérilet dans sa main à sa maman
je sais pas si elle l'a remis dans la
foulée